[Music]
when National Geographic asked me to
photograph this bat story I was really
excited because it was an opportunity to
work with some really interesting
scientists like Rodrigo and I get to
work with the species I've never seen
before very little has been studied
about these bats and so I was really
interested in figuring out how can I
show these bats predatory behavior in
captivity or in the wild so I'm working
on getting this flight cage set up for
tonight I barn Rodrigo are catching a
car top terrace for us to film and
record inside this flight cage so what
we've got is a camera flashes infrared
lights continuous lights bat detectors
all of this stuff is to try to catch a
crow top there's a woolly falls vampire
bat in the action of hunting of prey so
they've actually brought lab mice from
the University of Mexico and this is all
to try to better understand how this bat
hunts in the wild how does a bad
approach how does a bat kill the prey
the idea here is to recreate in the
environment outside so when the mouse is
moving around its going to be creating
some rustling sounds and we think that's
what the bat is using to locate the prey
there's one photograph in particular
that encapsulate this story I'm trying
to show the temple and the bat where you
can see and identify both things I've
got one light that's gonna light the bat
from below and by lighting it from below
I can actually project its shadow like a
bat signal against the wall of the
temple now from the very beginning I've
been studying how these bats leave their
roost I set up infrared video cameras
and I've watched them every night it
turns out for that first few meters as
they leave they all follow the same path
so I've got my sensor in place I've got
my lights in place now we just gotta
wait you know these scientists are just
getting started trying to understand
these bats and so to be able to come
here and actually contribute something
to understanding these animals through
photography that's really why I do what
I do
you
[Music]